we would like to think that we are great
guessers in finding out the voices of
our favorite animated characters but
sometimes these talented voice actors
throw us for a loop more often than not
a lot of the iconic cartoon characters
are voiced by the opposite gender and
guess what Bob's Burgers wins the award
for this one number one Nick Kroll quite
literally has a big mouth when it comes
to voicing cartoon characters Kroll's
got the voice for comedy and that's why
it was perfect that he played Lola you
like I want to go to a Pretty Little
Liars meet and greet this intensely
annoying character is someone this kind
of actor loves playing he also voices a
ton of the characters in the show The
Not So appropriate ones not that
appropriate as even a thing for big
mouth or anything what language is that
you're very beautiful we can all
remember him playing the off-putting and
annoying character Howard tuttleman on
Parks and Rec right number two this is
the first of many Bob's Burgers
characters that are voiced by the
opposite genders and first up is Tina
Belcher I don't think this will count as
an official patch but thank you Dan
Mintz brings this hilariously awkward
character to Life by well just being
himself he really doesn't change his
voice for this character why his natural
voice talking for a pretty weird
character just works how you doing Tina
you seem a little loggy well you seem a
little shy your face number three Linda
is the glue that holds the Belcher
family together and who better to voice
her than John Roberts this isn't the
only character from a cartoon he's
voiced you might also recognize them as
the voice of xyler on Gravity Falls
Bob's Burgers definitely pulled off the
gender-bending rules in the best way
possible so this is the BRAT who picked
on my Louise huh let me tell you
something Miss Priss number four does
Nancy Cartwright even need an
introduction and I'm so touched that all
of you would take the time to eat my
shorts lame out this veteran of the
industry has been voicing Bart Simpson
for over a whopping 30 years that's a
long time to hang out in the booth hi
caramba her prolific voice career also
led her to voice Chucky Finster in
Rugrats and Rufus in Kim Possible she
was definitely a huge part of our
childhoods and hopefully more
generations to come
number five we're not thrilled to be
talking about Courtney wheeler from
Bob's Burgers but we are thrilled to be
talking about David Wayne but it has
great Acoustics for singing
David's been involved in every step of
the production process from acting to
directing there's really nothing he
can't do in Hollywood number six these
sisters or brothers and Bob's Burgers
are two comedians in a pod Laura
Silverman voices the role of Andy pesto
a random role for a gal that can
literally voice anyone
I'm Tina no you're me oh you'd probably
recognize her voice as Cray's assistant
in Big Hero 6 and a bunch of the voices
in future worm number seven the other
half of the pesto Duo Ollie is voiced by
a household name can you guess here's a
hint she has the same last name as
Laura's I'm selling pens to benefit my
Bieber Scout Troop how many can I put
you down for none seven you guessed
right if you're a fan of stand-up comedy
then you've definitely heard of Sarah
Silverman she's also made her voice
acting rounds in numerous animated shows
like Robot Chicken and The Simpsons
number eight Brad bird made a small
character like Edna Mode into one of the
most memorable from The Incredibles
movies yes I'm sure you're gratitude is
quite inexpressible but Brad is not
usually stuck behind the mic he's
actually the Pixar director that brought
a ton of Classics to the Silver Screen
including Iron Giant The Incredibles and
Ratatouille this hard-working creative
deserved to take a great role like Edna
Mode but he's always pushing forward
with new projects and live action as
well if you repress your depressed
darling to impress you must Express
number nine Colleen O'Shaughnessy Rose
to stardom when she took on the role of
tails in the Sonic Universe it
it only took up the
tales in 2014 and then most recently got
to voice on the big screen in Sonic the
Hedgehog 2. let's just say Sonic fans
were extremely happy she was back for
the big film number 10 this Whimsical
shows iconic character is actually
voiced by a big time animator and oh
yeah he's actually its creator my fans
Pendleton Ward not only created
Adventure Time but also helps animate
the show and voice the character Lumpy
Space Princess we got a feeling he
intentionally wrote this character for
himself she's definitely an explosive
one
number 11 remember watching Saturday
morning cartoons as a kid and thinking
that voice sounds familiar well it was
probably Tara Strong
it weird before she took on the role of
Rocky J squirrel in the reboot of the
show The Adventures of Rocky and
Bullwinkle she'd already voiced dozens
of cartoon characters she may or may not
show up later on in this list cough
cough she will number 12. who else but
Carl ferulo to voice the mighty and
obsessive Grenda grendinator from
Gravity Falls
Brenda has entered the party Carl is
somewhat new to the industry compared to
the others but it didn't take long for
him to fall into the Hollywood voice
acting industry
you're out
too much number 13. remember what we
said about Tara Strong well she's back
in this list with a very memorable
character Timmy Turner no amount of
therapy will ever make this moment okay
with no debates this has to be her most
remembered character as the Fairly Odd
Parents is a National Treasure I wish
cousin would wonder
number 14 Debbie derryberry has played
almost every kind of Oddball character
you could think of but her most notable
one not a blast her big time role as the
Beloved Jimmy Neutron and the adventures
of Jimmy Neutron boy Genius marked her
place in the cartoon Hall of Fame oh and
she was also Draculaura on Monster High
which is super cool number 15 from
Pokemon to Dragon Ball super Veronica
Taylor has touched the hearts of many
animated super fans I won and I beat
Gary making us feel super old you know
it's been over 20 years since she
started as the voice of Ash Ketchum
longevity is key in Hollywood and if
you're anything like Veronica you'll
need so much success with one iconic
character number 16 masako nazawa aka
the queen of voicing anime characters
masako is a legend in the anime
Community having voiced Goku from Dragon
Ball since 1986. she's been working hard
with her voice acting skills way early
on in the 60s though and no she still
hasn't stopped nor should she
number 17 Regina King is an on-screen
star but some people seem to forget that
she voiced Huey and Riley Freeman in the
hit show The Boondocks we could just do
a little research and look it up I don't
know pick up a book surprisingly enough
Regina was actually brought on board to
voice yui but show creators had a
different idea in mind I originally was
only playing Riley and here we are in
our second season and I'm Huey and Riley
aside from The Boondocks King only has a
couple other minor voice acting roles
but she's definitely more recognizable
in live-action Classics like a
Cinderella story The Big Bang Theory and
Daddy Daycare number 18 and the the Emmy
goes to Pamela Aldon for Bobby Hill and
King of the Hill I can't believe I'm on
The Tonight Show I'm in Hollywood when
she auditioned for the role she did so
many different versions of Bobby that
she just gave up I just gave him a few
and I said pick one of course this
casting doesn't come as a surprise to us
Pamela can seriously do any project and
luckily for her this one became a staple
in her career launching her to success
for more Emmy nominations for on-screen
performances and better things and
Californication putting her in front of
a lot of TV bingers it's gonna be very
in your face
number 19. who voices Betsy crabs under
the sea
most of you
and you've seen the name Paul Tibbett
after watching the same DVD or VHS tape
of SpongeBob in the credits as a child
well at least we did that's because Paul
animated wrote and directed A lot of
those classic episodes so of course he's
gonna voice Mama Krabs and we're happy
he did I kiss you Scallywags have earned
a glass of lemonade number 20. okay
let's be honest here who else is always
waiting for a Consuela appearance in
Family Guy
well her voice actor is more present
than you think as Michael Robert Henry
also voices one of the creepiest
characters ever made Herbert
that's honestly all we can show of that
guy on this channel not that it really
matters to us but in the end who else
could have voiced these characters to
iconic stardom that's right nobody so
who do you think just knocked their
performances out of the park let us know
in in the comments